au 4e trimestre de l'année 2020 nous
avions 4034 points de deal qui été
recensé au 2e trimestre de cette année
nous avions 3069 points de dal qui étai
recensé ce qui fait une diminution de
965 en 2022 ce sont 16625 opérations qui
ont été conduites contre ces points de
deal qui ont provoqué un peu plus de
15000 gardes à vue un peu plus de 2000
écrou je vous je vous fais grâce des
chiffres de C de produit mais je noterai
quand même que 846 armes ont été saisies
à l'occasion de ces opérations et plus
de 11 millions d'euros d'avoir criminel
un autre dispositif qui fonctionne bien
c'est la plateforme de de signalement
qui permet sur l'application mass
sécurité aux citoyens de signaler de
manière anonyme les faits de trafic
qu'ils sont amenés à constater autour
d'eux ou ou près de chez eux en 2023
pour vous montrer quand même
l'efficacité de ce dispositif la moyenne
mensuelle de signalement reçu sur la
plateforme est de 850 et ce sont les
c'est c'est le vecteur de recueil
d'information le plus utilisé par les
les cross euh c'est 60 % des
informations recueillies par les cross
donc ce déploiement des cellules de
renseignement opérationnel sur les
stupéfiants
euh il y en a 104 autant que de
département aussi bien en métropole
qu'en outreem certaines sont permanentes
on regarde l' cité des trafics d'autres
sont sont temporaires ces cross en 2022
ont reçu 11214 renseignements dont près
de 5000 ont fait l'objet d'une note de
renseignement et ces notes de
renseignement ont évidemment entraîné
euh euh le démarrage de procéut
douignères ou de procédures judiciaaires
mais là aussi euh les chiffres vous
seront communiqués